[MUSIC PLAYING]
RICHARD GINGRAS: Well, thank
you for joining us today.
I'm Richard Gingras with our
eminent guest, Marty Baron.
So thank you for joining us,
those here and on the GVC.
Marty Baron, I think
you probably all
know to some extent.
I'll just give you a
little bit more background.
I didn't dig up anything
interesting is the truth.
I'm disappointed in my
reportorial abilities
in that regard.
Marty has basically
spent his career
in the newspaper business.
He's worked for basically
all the major national papers
in the United States.
You worked for the "LA
Times," "Boston Globe,"
"Washington Post," "New
York Times," "Miami Herald."
You were editor of
the "Miami Herald."
That was your first editor
gig, was the "Miami Herald."
Then Marty went on
to the "Boston Globe"
from what was it?
2002 to--
MARTY BARON: 2001.
RICHARD GINGRAS: 2001 to 2012,
where, among other things
that were accomplished
at the "Globe,"
was the large expose of sex
abuse in the Catholic church
of the archdiocese of Boston,
which the "Globe" obviously
led and won Pulitzers
for and got you
to the point of being portrayed
by Liev Schreiber in the movie,
"Spotlight."
So congratulations on that.
MARTY BARON: Thanks.
Thanks.
RICHARD GINGRAS: You've
dined off that one a bit,
I'm sure, the last two years.
MARTY BARON: Well,
I appreciate it
when people think
of him instead of--
his image comes up instead of
mine when they hear my name.
It's all right.
He's better looking,
more fit, and that's fine
if they think of him.
RICHARD GINGRAS: When
I meet at the "Post,"
I would often refer to
him as Liev and not Marty,
just to stump things a bit.
And then, of course, came
to the "Post" in 2012.
So it's obviously
been a great run,
and I would suggest-- in
fact, you admitted to me this
recently-- that the current
administration is likely
the most fascinating
story you will
have covered in your career.
I, personally, was not
going to load this up
with political questions,
but I did have one.
And I'm sure others
might have others.
Obviously, this
administration seems
to be different in more ways
than anyone can get comfortable
with, whether it
be Trump's ability
to go direct to the
people via Twitter,
his significant attacks
of the Fourth Estate,
so on and so forth.
Now, I know you've said that--
your answer to this is you
just do more hard work.
Just do more hard reporting.
But on the other hand, this
is a different environment.
And how has it
changed, if it has
changed, some of the
approaches that you
take in reporting stories?
Do you guide your reporters in
a different way on this story?
MARTY BARON: Well, no.
I think that we rely
on the same approaches
that we've always
had, and that is
that I think at the
core of our profession
is the process of verification.
We have to find out
what the real facts are,
what the truth is, and present
them in an honest, honorable,
fair, and accurate way.
And also, I believe,
an unflinching way.
Tell people directly
and straightforwardly
what we've found.
This is an
administration that has
sought to discredit the press,
to marginalize the press,
to de-legitimize the press.
And I think even to
dehumanize the press,
with the language of calling us
scum and garbage and the lowest
form of humanity.
And when that wasn't enough, he
said the lowest form of life.
And I thought he had
reached the limit there,
but then he came out with the
enemy of the American people.
So I don't know what's
next after that one.
But I think that
that's a strategy
to try to position
us as not being
an independent arbiter
of facts and truth,
but to position us as
a political opponent.
Not just an opponent
of him, but an opponent
of the American people.
I think that's
dangerous territory.
That's the kind of territory
that authoritarians
have typically
traveled, and I don't
think it's helpful to anybody.
What is our response?
Our response is to
keep doing our jobs.
Try to do them the
way that they're
supposed to be
done, and continue
to give the public the
facts that we feel they need
and deserve to know.
And then we'll see what happens.
The American people have to
make those kinds of decisions.
But we did that last
week with our look
at General Flynn, the
National Security Adviser.
We disclosed that
he had not told
the truth to the
American public,
nor to the Vice President,
when he said that he had never
discussed the potential
lifting of sanctions
with the Russian ambassador
to the United States.
We had nine sources
on that story,
and we published the story.
And initially, he had actually
denied to us-- when we first
talked to him, he
denied flatly that he
had had such a discussion.
And then we waited a
day, and on the next day,
his spokesman said he'd like
to revise his statement.
He'd like to say that he doesn't
remember whether it came up.
So then we published, and
it led to his departure
from the administration,
which, at first, was
described as resignation, and
then was described as a firing.
And then the President said--
after the President's spokesman
said that he was fired,
the President himself
said that the media had
treated him unfairly.
Now how you reconcile
our treating him unfairly
with the fact that he was fired
by the President, I don't know.
But somehow, they say that.
RICHARD GINGRAS: Well,
interestingly, in a sense,
the attacks that he's making
are beating a very wounded
horse, as it were.
You've made a point of
saying that the biggest
challenge facing news
organizations today
isn't the disruption
of the internet,
isn't the ability
to monetize news,
as challenging and important
as those questions are,
that it's really the
decline of trust.
So given that--
and I know you've
been deeply involved in this.
You've agreed to join
the Trust Project
effort, which is superb.
But what do you
think is the answer?
MARTY BARON: I think,
ultimately, the answer
is for us to continue
doing our job the way
that it's supposed to be done.
I know what the answer
is not, and that
is that it's not our job to
pander to any particular group
because we think that
that's our constituency.
And it's not our job to
placate any group because we're
under attack from them.
I think that we have
to be independent.
I don't think that
being independent
is a hostile act, as the
administration portrays it.
It's not an act of war.
I've said before we're not at
war with the administration.
We're at work doing our jobs.
And certainly, the
press has suffered
a decline in confidence.
That's true of pretty much
all major institutions,
except the military
in the United States.
But we've taken a particular
hit, and particularly
among Republicans,
over the last two years
when we've been under severe
attack from Donald Trump.
But I think that you
look back in history,
the press was under attack
during the Watergate
investigation.
And at that time,
there was actually
an ACLU report that
said the press had
gone from a position
of extreme security
to extreme vulnerability.
And they were very
concerned about the future
of the press in that environment
when it was coming under attack
from the Nixon administration.
Well, it turned out
that the investigation
of the administration, of
course, led by the "Washington
Post" in the Watergate
investigation,
turned out to be true.
There turned out to be all
sorts of bad things happening
in that administration,
and ultimately, Nixon
had to leave office.
And confidence in the press
soared to record levels
after that work.
So I think there are rewards
for us in just doing our jobs
and sticking to our
central purpose.
And that's what, certainly,
we at the "Washington Post"
intend to do.
RICHARD GINGRAS:
Let's probe into that.
And you're right.
At least in the United States'
history, trust in the press
hit pretty much an all-time
high around Watergate,
but has been declining
pretty steadily since then.
And interestingly,
it didn't drop off
a cliff with the internet.
It didn't drop off a
cliff two years ago.
It's been on a pretty
steady decline.
And I appreciate you saying that
we just need to do our work.
I guess the question
I would pose is,
do people understand your work?
Do they understand how
you approach your work?
And is there opportunity
to do things differently
in that regard?
MARTY BARON: Well, I don't think
people understand our work.
We have a whole generation,
maybe multiple generations,
of people who've grown up
essentially not reading
a newspaper, not
reading or turning
to other sources of information,
rather than those of us who
are in what is sometimes
derisively called the MSM,
or the mainstream media.
And so I don't think people
have an understanding
of how hard it is to do our
work, how much time it takes.
We can't just go
out and, forgive me,
Google all the information
that we publish.
It's not there.
Bob Woodward, of
Watergate fame, talks
about how he spoke to a class
at a very prominent university
once and said, how would
you do Watergate now?
And people said they would
go Google the information.
Well, that information
wasn't available on Google
until they unearthed it.
And so I don't think that
people understand just how
difficult it is to do this.
Because now so much information
is available instantly,
thanks to companies
like this one,
primarily a company
like this one.
But to unearth information
takes a lot more work.
And I think that is a problem.
And I worry about
people not understanding
just how much effort really
needs to go into this.
Now, how should we change?
As we've discussed on
any number of occasions
as part of this Trust
Project, we probably
need to show more of
our work to people,
show the original documents,
talk a little bit more
about who we spoke to, almost
in a footnotey kind of way.
That takes time.
It's typically not--
we haven't invested
in doing that sort of thing.
We've certainly
become more accustomed
these days to putting
original documents up,
to annotating those
documents, things like that.
But I would say that it's
a small portion of the work
that we do, and
it probably needs
to be a greater portion
of the work that we do.
That we, as news organizations,
need to be more transparent.
Now, that's difficult to do
that in all circumstances.
You take the investigation of
General Flynn, for example.
Those were nine confidential
sources and nobody
there is going to
go on the record
to tell you who they are.
And we're not putting
it on the record
because that was the
basis of our agreement.
And that's how we were
able to obtain the story.
And it's all true.
But in other
circumstances, I do think
that we have a greater freedom
and a greater necessity
of showing our work more fully.
RICHARD GINGRAS:
Let's go a little bit
beyond that because it certainly
has been my sense that,
given the dramatically different
ecosystem that we're in,
the massively larger ecosystem
of sources of content
that might be news,
might not be news,
and I don't mean that
in a fake news sense.
There's Joe Blogger and
there's the "Washington Post."
Vastly different environment.
People consume information,
form opinions in different ways,
which, to me, says, does
journalism, in its form
and substance and approach,
need to rethink itself,
given this different context?
I mean, in a sense,
more dramatically.
Because one of the
things I look at
and I see-- you've
got all of those.
You've got Joe's blog.
You've got a news
outlet that might
be known to be leaning
left and another
known to be leaning right.
And I go even to an
individual publication,
say, like the "Post," and I
see your fact-based coverage,
and I see opinion columns,
and I see the editorial page.
It leads to a lot
of mixed messages.
Are we at a time
and place when we
need to get even more
structured and rigorous in what
a credible, respected news
institution can or should be?
Not that everyone
will follow that,
but someone needs to start.
MARTY BARON: Well, we're
beginning to do that.
As you know, we've started
labeling pieces more
as opinion or analysis
or a review or something
like that to distinguish
them from news.
And this became ever more
urgent as so much of our work
is appearing on a lot
of different platforms.
And even if we were to
have labeling, let's say,
in the newspaper, it
didn't become apparent.
It wasn't visible on all
these other platforms
where we were appearing.
So not just on Google,
but on, let's say,
Apple News or on Twitter
or on Facebook or Snapchat
or wherever we are, and we're
pretty much everywhere--
and that's our desire to
be pretty much everywhere--
is to make sure that
these labels actually
travel with the story and
are visible, regardless
of where they're appearing.
And so we've worked
very hard to do that.
So that provides some
level of structure.
I'm not suggesting that
that's the total answer,
but it's one step
in the process.
AUDIENCE: What role
can and should schools
play in empowering students
to be media literate?
And what does
media literate even
mean when you go to a middle
school or a high school?
MARTY BARON: Right.
Well, that's a subject
of great interest to me.
I'm involved, in
an informal way,
with something called the
News Literacy Project.
And there are others, but that
is a prominent one and one
which I have a great belief
in their mission and the way
that they're going
about their work.
And that is to help
students really
understand how to be
more critical judges
of the information
that they're receiving,
to ask the right questions.
And that's all we
can really expect,
is that people ask the
questions and try to get answers
to those questions.
And to question the
sources that they have
and what is the
documentation that they have?
What is the basis
for saying that?
Are they providing
actual evidence?
Things of that sort.
So they've now-- they're
starting to scale up.
They have online tutorials.
They're making those available
to teachers at schools
throughout the country.
Fortunately, they've
been able to get
some additional foundation
support to do that.
But boy, is that a long process
and a difficult process,
and a process that doesn't
have any certain results.
We'll have to see
how that works.
I'm concerned about what's
happening more immediately
and how do we deal with that?
Now, to that, I'm
concerned about it,
but I don't really have any
answers to it, unfortunately.
I think that's a real--
we're hoping that maybe
Google can figure out--
working with us to figure
out how to sort out fact
from fiction and to give more
visibility to things that
are fact-based as opposed
to those that are not,
that are outright falsehoods.
It's tricky territory.
No question.
We were having a discussion
earlier today about that.
It is not easy to
do, especially when
you're considering free speech
issues and things of that sort.
But it's a worthy cause.
But certainly, we do
have to think long run
and we do have to
think about what's
being taught in middle schools
and high schools, colleges,
as well, and maybe for adults.
How to be more critical
evaluators of the information
that they're receiving.
RICHARD GINGRAS:
You're sitting here
in the home of Google
search, so what would
you suggest that we
do in this regard,
from our product experiences?
MARTY BARON: Give greater
prominence to the "Washington
Post."
I don't know.
Look, obviously,
that's just a joke.
But I--
RICHARD GINGRAS: And
it's not the first time
that joke has been said.
MARTY BARON: Although
feel free to follow my--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
RICHARD GINGRAS: Ezra
Klein, your buddy.
MARTY BARON: Well, he
recommended the "Washington
Post," too, I hope.
RICHARD GINGRAS: He said
the only reason he was here
was he felt it would get
him more Google juice.
MARTY BARON: I see.
Good for Ezra.
In any event, I don't really
know the answer to that.
I think that we've talked
about being more transparent,
that that should help.
Perhaps that can
actually elevate us
in the world of Google search.
More information about
the writers, who they are,
how they can be
contacted, things of that
sort being available to people.
Perhaps greater
weight given to people
who are actually in the region.
So why shouldn't-- let's
say, if the "Washington Post"
has a correspondent in Iraq,
who's putting his or her life
at risk to cover what's
happening there and is actually
providing information back
to the American public
and the public
throughout the world,
perhaps be given a bit more
authority than someone who is
sitting in a television studio,
who's never left the comfort
of a television studio, and
is not witnessing anything
firsthand.
Now how do you do that, it's
hard to do, hard to evaluate.
Because anybody can put
a dateline that says
they're from somewhere.
And they may or may
not actually be there.
There are very few news
organizations, relatively
few news organizations,
that actually have people
in conflict zones as we do.
But that could be a means
for giving greater weight,
because there should be greater
trust for people who actually
are eyewitnesses to events.
RICHARD GINGRAS: Right.
AUDIENCE: What's your
opinion on these third party
fact-checking organizations
and the approach that Facebook
has taken, for example, in
trying to farm out, I guess,
the quality assessments?
MARTY BARON: Yeah,
what Facebook is doing?
Right.
Well, we were invited
to be part of that.
We decided to wait
and see how it goes.
We have a very substantial
fact-checking organization.
We actually, just yesterday,
posted every fact check
on Donald Trump in the four
weeks since he took office.
There are a lot of fact checks.
I think it's interesting.
They obviously want
to do something.
I'm all in favor of
people doing something.
Readers are able to
tag things and say,
this should be checked.
And then that gets farmed out to
the fact-checking organizations
and they decide whether
they're going to pick that up.
And if they do,
and they question
the veracity of a story, then
that gets flagged in some way.
I don't think it covers a
lot of stories out there,
so I think it's going to
get a very small percentage
of the falsehoods that
are floating out there.
But it's a step.
We'll see how it goes to see
whether we would participate.
We're a little bit different
from these independent
fact-checking organizations,
because we're an actual news
organization.
And I think we--
it's interesting, as
is often the case,
it's just a
grievance from people
in the news organization-- is we
would make all the investment.
We would do all the work.
We would do the risk of being
targeted because of the fact
check that we did.
And outfits like Facebook
would not suffer.
They would not do
any of the work,
not make any of the
investment, but would
be able to say that they did
something about this problem.
Now I don't know that there's
another answer for them.
So I'm in favor of anything that
we can do that draws attention
to falsehoods.
But it's only going
to get a small--
it's only going to reach a
small portion of the problem.
RICHARD GINGRAS: Another
question from a Googler.
"What are your
thoughts on the future
of long form and
investigative journalism,
given the increasing
torrent of content
and decreasing attention spans?
Who will fund it and who,
demographically, will
consume it?"
MARTY BARON: I actually
think it's pretty good.
I think there's actually
an increased interest
in investigative reporting.
Certainly, I'm hopeful that
the movie about the Spotlight
team's investigation
of the Catholic church
created interest in
the general population.
I've seen a lot of
interest in what we did.
But more importantly,
I think what's
happened during the election
and subsequent to the election
is that there is an appropriate
demand on major news
organizations like ours to
do investigative reporting.
And also for there to be
investigative reporting
by regional news
organizations, as well.
I happen to think that that's
absolutely core to our mission,
that we have, as our central
purpose and our highest
purpose, holding
powerful institutions
and powerful
individuals accountable.
And certainly, that
includes the President
of the United States, who holds
the top position in the most
powerful country on Earth.
But what we should be doing
that across for politicians
and policymakers and other
powerful institutions
that are out there.
So there's, I think, an
increasing expectation
on the part that news
organizations should be doing
that work and an
increasing willingness
on the part of people to
actually pay for that.
And we're seeing that in
a surge of subscriptions
to the "Washington Post,"
and other news organizations
are seeing that, as well.
"The New York Times" has
reported the same thing.
And there these
are people who say,
I want you to do
this kind of work.
I am willing to support you
to do this kind of work.
In fact, I think it's
important that I support
you to do this sort of work
because otherwise, it's
not going to get done.
And the truth is
it's not going to get
done unless people support
news organizations that do it.
And so we do see that
that kind of reporting,
that in-depth reporting,
that's investigative
is well-read across the spectrum
by people of all age groups
and all demographic groups.
And that is really encouraging.
And it gets shared dramatically
through social networks
and has a very powerful effect.
But it is very expensive.
It's incredibly expensive to do.
It takes a lot of time.
We're in an
environment and a time
where people expect that they
can get information instantly,
no matter what, on about any
subject, thanks to you guys.
And the truth is,
that is not possible.
Not all information can
be obtained instantly.
There actually is work
that goes into obtaining
that information.
And so I think people have to
have an appreciation for how
much time, how much effort,
how much energy really needs
to go into doing
investigative work,
and understand that it takes
resources, including money,
to do that.
But I do think that there
is a surge of interest
in investigative reporting
and an increased expectation
that news organizations, like
ours, will do that and do it
consistently.
RICHARD GINGRAS:
How carefully do
you study consumption
patterns of your readers,
including to the point of, do
they read the full article?
How do you assess that?
What are you learning?
MARTY BARON: We do a
tremendous amount of-- we
have a tremendous
amount of data.
We have a tremendous
technology team, which
works closely with Google.
And we have a lot of data
about consumption patterns.
In fact, it's up on a board
in the center of our newsroom.
Not just the traffic, but
also the speed of a site,
very important.
How deeply people are scrolling
into stories, on average.
And we also look at that
across individual stories.
In fact, we're developing,
or have developed,
a new metric, which
we'll continue to develop
to judge the value of stories.
And one of them is,
how deeply into stories
are people actually reading?
So it's really important to us.
RICHARD GINGRAS: Has that
changed significantly
over the last few years?
Do you see patterns different
between mobile consumption
and desktop consumption?
MARTY BARON: I don't
know the data on that.
But our latest data
overall is that people
are spending more time on site.
So that's positive.
In terms of scroll depth,
I don't know the answer
to that question.
AUDIENCE: You said
earlier that there are
rewards in just doing our jobs.
I'm interested in
what that means
when the job of
journalism is changing
so much with digital
media and the internet.
MARTY BARON: Well, I think
there are all sorts of rewards.
Look, there are rewards in
terms of how many people
are subscribing to us.
When we're seeing an increase
in subscribers, that's one.
And we are.
Traffic-- we've seen
a surge in traffic
to the "Washington Post."
We are well over 100 million
unique visitors per month.
We were in November.
We actually surpassed
"The New York Times"
for domestic
traffic in November.
And that shows tremendous
progress for us.
But then there are other
rewards that are different.
And at the time, I was obviously
involved in this movie,
the "Spotlight" thing.
And I wrote a piece.
My colleagues demanded that
I write a piece about it,
so I did write a piece about it.
And the whole
premise of the piece
was that there are
awards like the Oscars.
Fortunately, it won the
Oscar for Best Picture.
But there are rewards.
There are rewards.
And the rewards were
the impact that it
had on ordinary people's lives.
And it had an enormous
impact on people's lives.
And I was at a
convention of survivors
of clerical sexual
abuse last year
and they asked me to be
their keynote speaker.
And normally, in
past years, they
would've had very
few people there.
But they had 300 people
attending the convention.
And person after
person came up to me
to tell me that the
reason that they showed up
for that convention
was because of the work
that "The Boston
Globe" did and that it
made an enormous difference.
That and the movie
persuaded them
to go public with the abuse
that they had suffered
and to see it as their
own personal obligation
to hold the church
accountable for its behavior
and not to keep
it secret anymore.
That's called a reward,
and setting aside
traffic and subscriptions and
monetization models and all
that stuff, to me, that's
the most important reward.
And it's exactly why
I'm in this business.
RICHARD GINGRAS:
In a sense, what
happened there is that
community saw "The Globe"
and that coverage
as their advocates.
And interestingly,
you tend to shy away
from that term in
journalism, of advocacy,
because it suggests
that somehow you're
taking a position on things.
I actually sometimes
wonder whether we shouldn't
go in the other
direction of, how
do you establish
that relationship
with your community such that
they understand that you are
advocates for their
interests, problems,
challenges in the community?
Particularly given how people
perceive the media today,
which is basically, you're
just bashing everybody
because you like to
have fun with it.
MARTY BARON: Yeah, right.
I agree with you.
I think that, as a
profession, as an industry,
we've done a terrible job
of explaining how we have
been advocates over the years.
Local newspapers
all over the place
have done incredible
work, in terms
of bringing to light
environmental dangers,
dangers to public
safety, abuse of power,
corruption, things like
that, across a whole range.
We don't tend to--
we give ourselves awards, but
we don't advertise what we did.
We don't have an advertising
campaign to talk about it.
And people tend to start
taking that for granted.
And they shouldn't
take it for granted
because if they
take it for granted,
it's not going to
happen anymore.
And there are politicians at
the local and state level today
who know that there's
absolutely nobody paying
any attention to what they do.
If you go to state houses
across this country,
the major newspaper
in the state,
which is the organization that
has the largest, the greatest
resources for news coverage,
may have only one person
in the state house.
And that individual is
in charge of covering
the governor, both houses
of the legislature,
all state agencies,
politics, and policy.
And now, how that
person can do one bit
of investigative reporting,
it's hard to know.
It's impossible to do
what they're expected
to do and to do it well.
They do it the best
they can, but they're
completely overloaded.
And so we have-- traditionally,
news organizations,
particularly "legacy" newspapers
that aren't "just newspapers"
anymore, have done
that kind of work
and they have not gotten
the credit for the work
that they did.
And they have been an
advocate for the public.
The notion that people
in this profession
would be described as an
enemy of the American people,
it so dishonors not just
them as individuals,
but the work that they have
done on people's behalf.
I can tell you that--
let's just take the church
investigation, the sexual abuse
investigation--
the people who were
survivors of sex abuse,
they did not view the
investigative team
at "The Boston Globe" as an
enemy of the American people,
as their enemy.
They viewed them
as their advocate
and they're very grateful that
they did the work they did.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
You mentioned earlier
moving towards trying
to footnote more and provide
source documentation to provide
more clarity into what went into
the investigative reporting.
To what end, or
what does that do
for you and for the paper,
in the sense that people that
don't already, I guess,
understand or believe
that what you've
report was correct,
are they actually
going to go and look
at the footnote and the source?
RICHARD GINGRAS: Can
I jump in on that?
To me, here's why
I think it matters.
It's not whether you
look at the footnote.
The comparison I would make is
you go read an academic article
in an academic journal and
you see the peer review
and you see all the
footnotes and so on.
You get a different sense
of the amount of seriousness
that went into that effort.
I think it's just about that.
It's not whether I delve
into the footnotes.
But does the very presence
of the footnotes or artifacts
of the effort that
went into the story
an important message in itself?
Feel free to disagree.
MARTY BARON: Well,
I agree, but it's--
well, I agree, and Richard
pressured me on this issue.
But I think there's merit in it.
And I think that,
look, not everybody
is going to read
every story and not
everybody is going to
read every footnote.
And that's just the way it is.
Not everybody does
a lot of things.
But for the people who want
to, who feel that they should,
then why would we not
make that available?
And if we can, why not do it?
I'll take this occasion
to mention that we
use annotations on documents.
And so we use Genius, actually.
And so here's this thing, and
it was created to annotate rap
and we use it to annotate Donald
Trump's press conferences.
But it doesn't
work on Google AMP.
And so you got to work on that.
It would be really
helpful if this thing
worked on Google AMP.
RICHARD GINGRAS: So noted.
MARTY BARON: OK.
AUDIENCE: You had spoken earlier
that you guys have incorporated
a lot of data.
So I wanted to know, especially,
what role that has in
affecting what's being
put out on the front page,
especially in the
editorial department.
Are you guys, as
editors, drawing a line
from AB testing to not
go towards clickbait?
And also prioritizing news,
especially longer issues that
aren't quite sensational
anymore like Fukushima or Flint
or things like that?
How are you drawing
that balance,
and how are you prioritizing?
Are you victims towards
marketing and advertising for--
MARTY BARON: Yeah.
No, we don't.
We make our news decisions
based on our editorial judgments
and our experience.
Look, we have a brand.
We have an identity.
We can't do anything that
undermines that brand.
If we were to revert
to just clickbait,
then people would say,
the "Washington Post"
isn't what the
"Washington Post" is.
That is not a successful
business strategy for us.
We do want to understand, what
are the qualities of the story?
Which ones actually succeeded?
We do want to reward people
who are producing stories
that might actually do well,
let's say, in terms of traffic.
Because that's just
part of who we are now.
We also-- for example,
we use data to--
one of the things that
we're doing right now
is trying to anticipate
which stories
are likely to be popular to
look at momentum indicators
and things like that.
And what's the purpose of that?
The purpose is, did we
build that story out?
We can't always anticipate which
story is going to be popular.
Have we built that story
out the way that we should?
Are there interstitial
links in there?
Are there other elements?
How have we--
what's the best way
to build that story out so
that somebody might actually
click on another story?
We also have a big data team--
it's not my area--
but a big data team that works
on the recommended stories
after you've read a story.
They're the ones who come up
with the recommended stories
based on reading patterns.
And basically, we took the
humans out of the picture
and they use whatever
algorithm it is and they
present the stories.
And it's improved
our performance.
We actually can anticipate
what people want to read better
than a human can.
AUDIENCE: Thank you so much for
coming to speak with us today.
It's been great.
And it's been really encouraging
to see how subscriptions
have surged at the "Post."
Hiring for investigative
journalists has also gone up.
And I guess my
question is more about
reaching Trump supporters.
You saw John Oliver
about two weeks ago.
He bought ad time on Fox to
reach Trump and his supporters.
And I just was wondering,
does the "Post--"
maybe not as blatant-- but
does the "Post" have a strategy
to reach his supporters in the
areas where they consume news?
Not necessarily on Fox, but
just a strategy in general?
MARTY BARON: We don't really
have a strategy for that.
The reality is that
there are a lot
of Trump supporters who read
us, if only to criticize us.
So that's OK.
And there are a lot
of conservative sites
that actually pick
up our stories.
Drudge is a big driver
of traffic and they
pick up our stories
all the time,
the ones that conform to
their particular worldview.
So they are reading us.
We have a wide variety of
opinion people, as well.
And we have, in a
very determined way,
sought out people who have
opinions that are more in line
with Trump so that we have
a wide variety of opinion.
We have people across the
spectrum, as I think we should.
So that's really
what we're doing.
And we also, very
systematically,
are talking to Trump supporters
to hear their voices.
So a couple of weeks
into the administration,
we went out to a rural area in
Maryland, which is generally
Democratic, but it is now.
It didn't used to be.
But rural Maryland, where
it was a center of Trump
support, to listen to
what they had to say.
And what they had to say was
quite different from what
you might hear elsewhere.
In fact, Trump himself
read the piece.
He wrote a note to the
reporter on the story.
Somebody must have taken
a picture of what he wrote
and then he sent
it to the reporter
and thanked her for
doing this story.
And I told her, by the
way, that autograph's not
worth anything
unless he sends you
the original piece of paper.
And then when he did his
rally in Florida, afterwards,
we talked to the people
there and gave voice
to their point of view,
which I think we should.
These are all American
citizens, people
who live in the United
States who are entitled
to have their voices heard.
And we should, as a
news organization,
make sure that we're listening
to all voices out there.
AUDIENCE: I read a lot of
news and I consistently
read the "Washington Post."
It's my favorite
newspaper, so thank you.
MARTY BARON: It's what?
AUDIENCE: It's my very favorite
newspaper, so thank you.
I'd love to hear about
how-- what is it--
how is your approach different
than other news organizations
in the United States?
For example, "The
New York Times."
What is it that you feel sets
your news organization apart?
MARTY BARON: For one, I
think that we've adapted,
and I should say embraced, the
web in a way that I think--
perhaps more quickly
and more fully
than other news
organizations have.
And that extends to--
we've felt that we need
to be true to our values
and our principles, but that
the current digital environment
requires us to find new
forms of expression,
to tell stories
in different ways.
So we have now, for years,
been telling stories
and incorporating all the
tools that we have today--
audio, video,
original documents,
annotations of documents,
interactive graphics--
all within the corpus
of an individual story.
We also tell those stories in
a much more conversational way.
I think a much more accessible
way, where you're not just
hearing an institutional
voice, but you're
getting the authentic
voice of the author.
I think people now want
a sense of authenticity,
and I think that that kind
of writing style actually
is more authentic.
We've paid a lot of
attention to our headlines.
We were talking
about that earlier.
They're written in a much more--
they're not what I call
"newspaper headlinese," which
has to be squeezed
into a defined space.
But they are intended to
get people's attention.
I was in Spain a few weeks
ago, and some of the students
there at the
University in Pamplona,
they said, well, a
lot of people now
will only read the headlines.
How do you get them
to read a whole story?
And I said, write
a good headline.
And they'll click on the story.
But the headline has to be
true to the actual substance
of the story.
So we've really worked on that.
And I think that you're
now seeing "The New York
Times" begin to change
its style of headlines.
You're beginning to see them
do stories that incorporate all
the tools that we have, that
look less like a newspaper
story and more like
something that's
actually native to the web.
I think we recognize
that the web is
its own medium, in the same way
that newspapers were a medium.
Then radio came along
and you didn't just
read newspaper stories on radio.
And then television came along
and you didn't read a radio
script on television.
And then the web came along
and we, in the industry,
we just put up
newspaper stories.
And we said, ah-ha,
we're digital now.
It didn't work that way.
And then we said, ah, we'll
let's put them up faster.
Well, it helped, but
it wasn't the answer.
And now we're
saying, no, there's
actually a distinct way of
writing and communicating,
that this new medium has
its own medium, as well.
And as has been pointed out to
me, it's not just a new medium,
it's new mediums.
Because now we're having
to think about, well,
how do we disseminate
news and information
on Google Home or Amazon
Echo or something like that?
What about podcasts,
which, at one point,
died out and now have
seen a huge resurgence?
It's a different medium.
It's not radio.
It's different.
It's distinct.
What about when you have
some outfit like Snapchat
comes along?
OK, what are we
doing on Snapchat?
And we just started on
Snapchat a couple of weeks ago.
It's a very different way
of telling that story.
And so I think we've done that.
I also think that we are just--
I hope that we're more
unflinching in the way
that we tell the stories.
That after we've done
all this research,
that we don't hesitate to just
say, this is what we found.
This is what we've concluded.
We're not beating
around the bush.
We're just going to
tell it to you straight,
and I think we do that
more than, perhaps, most.
RICHARD GINGRAS: In
your mind, I hear
a lot of comments these days
of there's too much news.
I don't have time to consume it.
Article's too long.
I don't know whether
these are representative.
But these are expressions.
And I, myself, aren't sure.
I think one interesting
dynamic of the web
is this paradox of numbers,
where if everything doesn't
get to the hundreds of millions,
then somehow it's not working.
Whereas newspapers have
been very effective
getting the right
information into the right
heads, historically.
What's your take on
evolution of form?
And there are the
Snapchat explorations
and you're just
getting started there.
MARTY BARON: I think
that we just don't know.
I think that people
are getting information
in all sorts of
different ways now.
It's a real challenge for those
of us who are in the business.
We're finding
that, first of all,
people don't want
to go look for news.
They want the news to find them.
They don't want to have
to go find the news.
And so that's a lot of
what's happening right now.
It's an old fashioned
way of delivering news,
but we have email newsletters,
which are incredibly effective.
People sign up for
these newsletters.
They end up in their inbox
and if they're done well,
they're very
attractive to people.
And we get a lot of
traffic out of that.
And we like it, frankly, because
it's direct to the reader
and we don't have to go through
an intermediary, not even
Google.
RICHARD GINGRAS: Not even us.
MARTY BARON: And so that's nice.
But also, video is becoming
incredibly important.
People seem drawn to getting
information off of video, so
explanatory videos.
We're doing a lot of them,
just as Ezra Klein at Fox
is doing those sorts of things.
Animations, you name it.
Two-minute videos that help
explain complex subjects.
With Snapchat, we're taking
stories that we've already done
and breaking them down
into their essence
and then presenting
those in a Snapchatty
kind of way, whatever that is.
And we just started, so
we'll see if it's working.
They liked what we
presented as our proposal.
They said it was the
fastest onboarding they've
done for any organization ever.
And we'll see how it works.
And so we just recognize that
people are getting information
in all sorts of different ways
and we want to be everywhere
they are.
And we will adapt.
They don't have to--
we're not expecting people to--
well, here we are,
the "Washington Post."
You're just going to
have to come to us
and adapt to us, who we are.
And if you don't, then
we're going to scold you.
That's not our view.
And say, you're not
performing your duty
as an American citizen
or something like that.
Our view is that people
want to get information
in lots of different ways
and we will adapt to the ways
that they want to get
information, while still
staying true to our
values and our principles.
RICHARD GINGRAS: Are you--
I can remember a
call a while back,
I was telling the
folks at ProPublica.
And one of the things they
did with their investigative
journalism pieces, which
I thought was clever,
was they basically
said, all right.
This is a 3,500-word piece
here, or an 8,000-word piece.
They would basically
chunk it out.
They almost meme-ified it.
And they would do
a series of tweets,
a series of social posts,
the whole point being,
can I use every one to
get some little nugget
into people's heads?
Have you played
around with that?
MARTY BARON: We
haven't done that yet.
It's a good idea.
I think we should
think about that.
One of the things-- we have a
large audience engagement team
and we do need to
think about, when
we're doing major
projects, how are we
alerting people to
what's in that project
and finding points of entry?
So yeah, I think
it's a good idea.
AUDIENCE: If you look at a
media outlet as an information
processing system, then things
like Donald Trump timing
communications to
dominate the news cycle
starts looking like a
denial of service attack.
And things like
Pizzagate start looking
like a man in the middle attack.
Have y'all thought about any
kinds of procedural changes
to make media outlets more
secure against these kinds
of manipulations?
MARTY BARON: Hm.
I'm trying to information
process that one myself.
RICHARD GINGRAS:
In other words, is
Jeff going to buy Twitter
so he can shut it down?
MARTY BARON: No.
I have no idea what
Jeff is going to do.
He doesn't tell me
what he's going to do.
But I think that's
highly unlikely.
Look, we do have--
every politician wants
to manipulate the media.
Not just politicians, but
companies and individuals,
and everybody out there
is trying to manipulate us
in one fashion or another.
This President has certainly
used the early morning
hours and the evening hours
and, I don't know, all hours
to put out tweets.
There was a-- a lot
of the suggestions
at the beginning
were, you should just
ignore these tweets.
Pretend they didn't happen.
The problem is that
it turns out that we--
and we didn't ignore
them, because guess what?
They were coming from the
President-elect, and then
the President.
So we thought, maybe they
actually have meaning.
And it turns out they actually
are declarations of his policy.
They are reflections of
what he really thinks
and what's going to
appear in policy.
So we should be paying
attention to these tweets
and we should not
be ignoring them.
And we obviously want
to put them in context.
We want to do more
reporting around them.
But I don't think that
we can ignore them.
Now covering these things,
these denial of service attacks,
as you might call them, that's
not the end of the line.
There's a lot more work for
us to do, and we do that work.
So the investigations,
the fact-checking,
exploring the impact on
ordinary people, which
is of surpassing
importance-- those
are things that we
do all the time.
So I don't know that we can--
he is the President
of the United States.
He does hold the top position
in the most powerful country
on Earth.
I don't think that we can--
it's going to be
pretty hard to--
and I don't think we
should be shutting down
that source of information
or whatever it is.
And we have to
cover it and then we
have to put context around it.
AUDIENCE: The brand of the
"Post" and the mainstream
media, in general, is these
elite, old institutions
that lean left, which I
don't have a problem with.
I read you guys.
I'm a big fan.
But I'm curious if, from
a branding perspective,
you feel that there is a vacuum
in the conservative media
for voters to turn to
outlets that they trust.
And since there aren't as many
reputable conservative outlets,
most voters turn towards Fox.
And so I'm curious if you
think that maybe you guys could
partner or somehow help
new organizations spring up
to provide news to these
people that isn't just
from your editorial page
from a right-leaning source.
MARTY BARON: Well, look.
I mean I don't know that we
can create some sort of spinoff
for them.
We try to provide trustworthy,
verifiable news on our site
and on our pages and
on various platforms.
That's what we do.
I think that there are news
organizations that they trust,
as you point out.
Fox-- they trust Fox a lot.
Breitbart has come up and
that's actually posing
a competitive challenge to Fox.
And so I don't know
how much room there is.
And I don't think that it's our
job to try to pander in any way
to any group, as I said before.
I don't think that
we should do that
in order to create a
business for ourselves.
We have a business
today, where we
think that we are, in a
very honorable, honest,
straightforward way, trying
to gather information,
to verify that information,
and to present it
in an unvarnished way
to the American public
and to the public of the world.
And that's what
we're committed to
and that's what
we're going to do.
We know-- I know--
that we are not going
to make everybody
happy all of the time.
That is just not possible.
We would be absolute mush
if we tried to do that.
And so we're not going
to get everybody.
But we do, actually-- over
the course of a month,
given that we've surpassed
100 million unique visitors
in the month, we're
reaching about--
in any month-- we're
reaching about a third
of the US adult population,
which is pretty good.
It's pretty good.
I think it's more
than Fox, actually.
And it's more than
most news outlets.
We come in a bit under
CNN and sometimes we
pass "The New York Times,"
but most of the time,
they're a little
bit ahead of us.
So we're up there and growing.
And we would hope
that by doing what
we think we ought to be
doing that we would just
reach more people.
And we believe in
our independence.
AUDIENCE: Any changes from
the Jeff Bezos acquisition
of the "Washington Post?"
MARTY BARON: Yeah.
Quite a few.
Look, he came in.
He changed our
strategy immediately.
We were a paper that defined its
mission as being for and about
Washington, so largely
regional, with a recognition
that within our region was the
capital of the United States.
And he said, look,
I think it should
be a national strategy and
even an international strategy.
He said, the internet has beaten
up this business really badly
over the years.
It's taken away
a lot of things--
our security, things like that.
But it also offers gifts, and
the primary gift that it offers
is free distribution.
And why would we not take
advantage of its gifts
if we're going to
suffer from the things
that it's taken away from us?
And here we had
that opportunity.
We were the "Washington Post."
It was a well-known brand
that hadn't actually
exploited that brand on
a national scale or even
an international scale.
And when you think
about internationally,
when people talk about
the United States,
they often substitute,
as a synonym, Washington.
So there were great
opportunities for that.
On top of that, I think Jeff--
first of all, I would say
he brought two main things.
He brought, obviously,
financial capital,
which we needed in order
to experiment in the way
that I think is necessary
in the current environment.
And a lot of people have
just focused on that.
But he also brought
intellectual capital.
He brought new
ideas and a new way
of thinking, which we sorely
need in this business.
And it was not just a
knowledge of technology
and the internet, which
is very important,
and he obviously has a
sophisticated understanding
of that, but a knowledge
of consumer behavior.
We happen to be a
consumer-facing business
and he has a big
consumer business.
And it's really helpful
to have somebody who
has that kind of experience.
He also forced-- he pushed
us, I should say, to embrace--
not just adapt to the internet,
to actually embrace what it is.
So that involved
a lot of things.
These new forms of
storytelling that we're doing,
greater use of aggregation
when appropriate.
Create a rigor of thinking
about what kind of initiatives
we undertake.
I remember our first
meeting with him.
He was like, well, what are
the parameters for our--
he asked for our ideas.
And he said, well, what were
the parameters you used?
And our very limp answer
was, well, we just
thought they were good ideas.
And he basically
said, well, what will
appeal to a national audience?
And frankly, what might
appeal to a younger audience?
Because if we don't have a
younger audience in the future,
we're not going to have
any audience in the future.
And he was somebody who
thought very long term.
So that was really important.
And so I think,
across the spectrum--
and also, our investments,
the investments that were made
were in, I would say,
two primary areas.
One was the editorial work
that we do, our news coverage.
And the other-- journalistic
work that we do.
And the other was
technology, that we really
needed to be leaders
in technology,
which I think we have become.
We've been consistently rated
in the last several years
as among the most innovative
media companies in the world.
And I think if you talk
to the people many of you
have dealt with, I think it's
a pretty impressive crew.
We are actually now
selling our technology
to other media companies.
So he's really emphasized that.
A greater use of data,
like we talked about,
how we might use that.
It's really important.
We are becoming much more
of a technology business
than we ever were in the past.
And if we are not
leaders in technology,
I don't believe that we will
thrive, or even survive.
And so he's put a lot
of emphasis on that.
And I would add--
and certainly, this
was true of our previous
ownership, which
everybody revered.
The Graham family ran
the "Washington Post"
brilliantly for the 80 years
in which that family owned us.
But the time came where
things had changed,
and we really did need new
ideas and we did need capital.
And Jeff is incredibly committed
to our mission of holding
government accountable.
And he says all the time,
democracy dies in darkness.
We need to shine a light in
dark corners, things like that.
He believes in that very firmly.
He's talked about
that very eloquently
and he has lived up to
that mission every day
that he has owned us.
RICHARD GINGRAS: And that's
a pretty fabulous end,
though I actually am tempted
to ask the audience one
question before you depart.
How many of you are subscribers
to the "Washington Post" today?
Excellent.
How many of you subscribed
in the last three months?
Very good.
How many of you are going to
go home and subscribe today?
[LAUGHTER]
MARTY BARON: There are some
really good deals out there
for those of you--
very good introductory deals.
RICHARD GINGRAS:
Well, Marty, I thank
you hugely for coming and
spending the time with us.
I know it's been
beneficial to us.
And it has been an excellent
partnership with the "Post"
and I look forward to that.
But most importantly, thank
you for doing what you're doing
at such an extraordinary time.
MARTY BARON: Great.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]